[Music]
when the calendar flipped to 2020
we had no idea it would be a year unlike
any other from the coronavirus pandemic
to mass demonstrations and a racial
reckoning
all while a bitter and sometimes surreal
presidential race played out
while it may not be a year we want to
relive it is a year we need to remember
that's why the smithsonian is building a
collection of artifacts that tell the
story of 2020.
here's christina ruffini when
new york nurse sandra lindsay got the
first coveted 19 vaccine in america
it was historic so historic that the
smithsonian snatched her socks
and her socks you stole her socks and we
stole her socks
technically they curated them with
permission along with her scrubs
id badge and the very vial that held her
shot we didn't just want
the empty bio we wanted to preserve
something about this person
who was really kind of selected for this
moment
deep in the archives of the national
museum of american history
curator dianne wendt focuses on the
history of medicine
specifically vaccines and
pharmaceuticals 2020 was a big year for
you
2020 was a big year for for medicine yes
i think so
it's a big year for everyone actually
it's all here
from brass and graves scab keepers to a
bottle of jonas salk's original polio
inoculation
and now the covid 19 shot we realized
that we really had a responsibility
for beginning to collect material
so in the future historians the public
whoever can try and understand this
event
when it comes to history-making moments
does anybody have any question the last
two years have
had a lot of them we will stop
the steal but it's sometimes hard to
recognize history when you're living
through it
you can't cry victim when you report
fake news
all the time presenting a new challenge
for the nation's memory keepers
and secretary of the smithsonian lonnie
bunch the key is
to think about how do you
document today so that people
who don't know this story will be able
to understand it
a generation two or three generations
from now with the museum and its offices
closed due to the pandemic
curators formed quick reaction teams to
document the remains
of particularly important dates
like the black lives matter protest in
lafayette park
or the january 6 riot at the u.s capitol
what i think is important for the
smithsonian is to recognize that
we have to make sure that america
remembers and so
the brilliant staff collected amazing
things this was a slogan that was used
not just in washington d.c but at
protests
around the country after the murder of
george floyd in the political history
department claire jerry usually focuses
on campaign swag
but she also collects from important
protest movements
this sign was not carefully made that
morning
it was painted it was riveted onto a
post
so it tells us a lot about the what was
going on behind the scenes
her 2021 collection includes a
ceremonial copy of the vote tally that
certified the election
the very thing the january six rioters
were trying to stop
why do we need to have these posters for
the next generation
this shows that people were there it
shows what people were thinking
when you stand in front of a poster or
an object in our museum you're standing
in front of
that other person who touched that
object 100 years ago
we can't know how americans 100 years
from now will view current events
or those of us who lived through them
but by collecting these real-time relics
the smithsonian hopes to help future
visitors
put themselves in our shoes or rather
a soft colorful pair of sandra lindsay's
socks
for cbs this morning saturday christina
raffini washington
i'm not sure there are some parts of
2020 that people want to revisit
immediately
yeah maybe with little distance yeah
posterity this is all for posterity yeah
but we do need to process and give it
some distance i agree
and then take a look at it i think for
those of us living through so what is
that five or ten or twenty five years
generation whatever else i mean you
asked a good question about the socks
though do they wash them
before they put them jeffrey todd they
should we're moving on now
okay